i remember when you first got smallville
well when i first got
when we first got smallville i had it
sounds fancy
but it wasn't five thousand dollar
cadillac el dorado
uh convertible that didn't run very well
it looked good but it was a piece of
[ __ ] i bought it for five grand
and you let me keep it at your mansion
if i may say
uh in agora hills i lost it don't don't
let him kid you i lost it folks i lost
it but you had one
that's more than i had a jet too i
launched that too all right well
you know we could talk about that but
right now i'm talking about my shitty el
dorado catalonic convertible johnny
el dorado what was like from smoking the
bandit yeah i remember you came over one
day
you have i don't know if you had any
more but you had the general lee in your
garage yeah i do i have
i have two of them now okay so i go you
guys see it and you're like yeah
and i was kind of nervous asking you and
you're like let's go for a ride
and we got in of course i jumped through
the window
it was hard because i just had surgery a
few years back so i was a little stiff
but we drove down the highway and we got
looks and the girls i was like oh my
gosh i mean
generally some people that were younger
were like what the hell are these guys
but it was my brother i got my brother
it was before face time he was like no
way
it was so exciting but you're so giving
you're so good to me
you eventually said come get your piece
of [ __ ] i can't keep it here anymore but
i it was
after about a year or two and i
understood that but you know those days
did you have a great time doing the show
did you love doing the show
did you uh i mean i i could tell that
you were just really enveloped sort of
in the
in the role you took it so seriously
which i think really helped the
character
in the show well thank you uh yeah i
have uh i have
you know it's been a long time so i have
i have great
great memories uh another part of me
remembers though being
kind of pissy about scripts or about
uh the shallowness
of uh of
the writing at times but you know now i
realize you know
it's hard it's hard to turn out 24
stories worth watching a year
it's hard to do that so yeah but i
didn't i didn't really know
and i just did a youtube video um
i do i answered duke's questions and
people always ask me my favorite episode
and somebody said what is your least
favorite episode
and i had to tell them that when we did
it we did one
called the ghost of general lee and i
remember
reading it and thinking oh great now
we're stealing from mark twain this is
tom sawyer we show up at our own wake i
mean these guys are so lame
years later it became my favorite
episode
so once i became a member of the
audience
rather than a member of the cast i loved
every minute of dukes